I mean if I was being interrogated like
that you'd get all my secrets
what secrets you hungry you just tossed
it over the fire and it cut is that how
cats work if we want to make dinner we
need to leave in like 30 minutes
yeah let's just get takeout these guys
are so smart they're geniuses right and
like they look really nice and they want
to help him he's like dad hot this
family deserves a break at this plane
right play it played the goddamn episode
this guy he thinks he's gonna go home he
just wants to go home and watch
WrestleMania are you kidding me no one's
talking about the blood
if you slice her jugular everywhere
everywhere there's a semen where's the
semen
maybe he didn't finish oh wow see Jerry
in those closing arguments I mean he was
indeed cool I didn't save his Dean cool
I said he was Jerry very compassionate
all right [ __ ] marry kill Dean Jerry
Avery none of them Mike knows Mike are
you kidding me how did this guy get a
license to be a lawyer are you kidding
me wait but there are two more episodes
what Oh maybe something good happens to
them that's it that's it maybe
God said no no we we can rewatch them
the jinx yeah the jinx this is it binge
watch this we ate our six hours you've
been weak today tonight